[Music]
what is up there reject nation strike
first strike hard no mercy
say hi to christ on your way to hell
guys
three by four nope four by three
in and out sounds good but hey hit that
like button if you end up enjoying our
reaction once you subscribe and click
that notification bell to get notified
when we're actually the next cobra kai
is up we got our buddy andrew gordon
movie source channel knows karate kid
better than ralph macchiato also
full-length watch long as we sync up
with the time code or over at our
patreon page we cover so much crap over
there you're gonna be so turned off by
the time you join and become a superior
jack it's like going to netflix you're
like i don't know what to watch but i'm
gonna stay pledged anyway that's how you
do it thanks to the boys at prep for
helping us edit down these highlights
let's get bad ass up in here
yep
[Music]
nice
good reference
so better than one
getting bill and ted flashback bill and
ted yep
ooh the cat's looking swole huh yeah
that dc body
i love it trouble in paradise i noticed
you two came in separate cars oh we're
fine she just wants to take things slow
i didn't know that was a speed you could
go oh yeah wise ass
ah i keep bishop hawkeye
the the green stuff in the back no
problem
it'd be great if william zobka played
clint barton's brother hey you the son
what'd you do switch over to whopper
juniors let's go to growth spurt
[ __ ] still a piece of crap
[Laughter]
miguel how's school going uh good uh
great actually straight days this
semester
oh wow i don't know karate but i know
crazy and i will use it i'd like to go
to stanford
well that's a pretty impressive school
yeah i think it's like number six in the
country the campus is beautiful it's
definitely a tough choice but that
tuition wow
we're also thinking about santa monica
college right miguel arnold went there
smc is great too it's right by the beach
have you checked out their campus no
actually i have
whoa
please just a little wine right
this whole episode's going to deal with
miguel's shameless
just gonna go for a little ride clear my
head
made you creme brulee i'm looking for
robbie keane
mr keane yeah you have a visitor my
brother sean payne said you could help
me
i know shawn had a brother
is he out i wrote it into the season
[Laughter]
one of them knows karate this is a dojo
[Laughter]
sean payne was one of the toughest guys
in juby kicked my ass a few times now we
see where bane got his hold
of course
catch a fish
but since i know you eagle fangs like a
little bit of competition we're gonna
make it interesting your bare hands are
all you use
and all you need
gross
[Music]
what is the plan here
oh god i'm tired of being right
must have watched lethal weapon
but the eagles hungry
doesn't
hesitate it'll dive down at 100 miles an
hour to snatch its prey
it doesn't wait around for a fish to
jump on its feet talons
it's not talent it's instinct
you're gonna jump from this roof
to that one
what
are you crazy that building is like five
nights a win we're at least 14 natai
please don't use me as a system of
measurement quiet
what if we fall that's what the
mattresses are for
if we miss the mattresses try not to oh
my all right who's first
none of them seen the matrix come on
this is easy the jump program then i
guess you'll be waiting a long time
because we're not jumping
how am i supposed to fight if i haven't
had any training yet
to be a cobra kai
you have to have a killer instinct
i was gonna say the training is nothing
the will is everything
kick his ass kenny look at this
we don't have time for losers
or cowards
i know this chinese restaurant with a
big-ass fish tank we can go there and
practice
i don't want to see that
i yeah my mom's just having some car
troubles
what kind of trouble can i help oh no
it's not that big a deal she's calling a
tow truck let me call one of my guys
we'll bring it in that's that's not
necessary miguel i do this for a living
let me help
remember his mom used to have card
trouble
[Laughter]
they're more alike than he understands
my dad wouldn't want us doing this i'll
give me a break you do everything your
mommy and daddy tell you to do
they told you to jump off a bridge would
you
you're telling me to jump off a building
yeah onto another building
[Laughter]
you don't have the best judgment oh you
want to talk judgment how about smashing
into my firebird and driving off with
your goal who's going to say that i'm a
teenager who's made a couple of mistakes
you're a 50-something-year-old man who
lives alone drinks all day and clearly
hasn't figured out his own life
wow if i did everything my parents
wanted me to do i've been wearing a suit
and tie and some worthless job while i
weighed out the clock
and now i get to do what i love every
damn day
i get to try to help kids like you find
their own way if you want to sit in the
back seat your whole life johnny
it's the sweat off my back
call shotgun yo you wanna stand in line
with me to buy some new nikes
how many secrets do you need hey you
look good in ducks oh sure
he's gonna mentor kenny i just reached
out to an old friend
but if the past bothers you so much
maybe you've got some unresolved issue
you [ __ ] or did you look in the
mirror and realize what you've become
you're just an old man
in the last chapter of his life
clinging to some [ __ ] happy ending
i don't know it looks healthy
[Music]
afraid you're a little rusty
[Music]
not bad hey even flinch there's still
time to finish what we started
choice is yours
what exactly is the
overall
plan spread that kobrakai everywhere
yeah all over the world like a plague
i can't be your tutor
i have to focus on the all valley
what
don't kick those bully's asses robbie
oh [ __ ] how did they do that no
impressive
i can show you a couple moves
always look your opponent in the eye
ready
fight
i always look i am you know mr larusso
we really appreciate you fixing this for
us
oh i'm not gonna do it but don't worry
i know a great repair guy really
who
make yeah know anything about fixing
cars hey neither did i when i was your
age
look at me now i'm the guy with the
billboards right when i get done with
you who knows you might have a few
billboards of your own someday chopping
prices if they make billboards for guys
going to community college
i didn't even go to college
really
yeah it was a whole movie
any spare cash she had she put in a jar
she called it the daniel fund
dude you wasted your college money
thanks to a little ice-breaking contest
i came back with more money than i left
with
so you used that to invest in the
dealership nope no i blew that on a
bonsai tree store
you could reach any goal you want it
just might mean taking the circular path
you have a good head on your shoulders i
know you can make it happen i love them
together yeah
you all failed grab your crap let's go
do it sam
come on
i saw trinity do this i could do it how
hilarious would it be she just plummets
to the ground it slams on concrete
straight down she's gonna fall into her
mercedes
[Music]
oh damn what a shot yeah they did what
the hell that was
pretty weird oh good tuck and rolls
thought they were going to do like
mission impossible where he breaks his
foot now jump back
[Laughter]
the ground is merely a mirage
damn he does have great hair after all
these years you know he's younger than
ralph macchio too
this
hurts the mind
this is awesome but what about the dojo
i mean we were just about to open it you
will
no i can still pay my half of the rent
even more
i just won't be able to be there with
you but i can't do this without we just
got tattoos man
sprung this on me earlier we started
this together
we got to see it through together
maybe someday but i've got toxic sludge
to dump
you can get through anything
cause you got me
i didn't leave you behind in the war
you two seem so much nicer i know the
things ptsd does to people
terry silver reborn yes let's do it
[Music]
i just love the music
the ponytail was the key i know you want
to take things slow maybe we should talk
about this later i'm tired of waiting
i want to talk about this now with you
[Music]
oh okay your mom's friends
hola
hola oh that was gonna be worse carmen
when it comes to us i can't sit in the
back seat any longer
shut up you had me in a love look i know
there's a lot of [ __ ] to figure out but
we'll figure it out together i don't
know if they call that you want to
translate
i think they got it
all right
hey johnny
okay
yeah yeah
yeah
kiss hard
that's right good job mr park
do that all day
all right kenny mr park make this quick
hey you guys sensei
headbutt his balls
charge
look at running to mommy oh that's all
we needed there you go
stop making fun of me
where you going mr payne
do that again
take your spot get him a geek
l.a noir throw
[Laughter]
damn it how do they make it look so easy
on hillbilly hand fishing
it's just like catching the fly with the
chopsticks oh yeah
oh my lee
walk in a circle
the circle
it's working they're going under the
board
[Music]
we have a winner now eat it
it also does a pretty good job of
keeping the sweat out of your eyes
[Music]
uh-oh uh-oh jealousy you're taking my
miguel
[Music]
what the hell
[Music]
oh [ __ ] guys
[Music]
got some drama brewing now now
uh
well you know it's time for a
well-placed misunderstanding just
it's gonna be a stun soon
that's true it's a good point all right
guys there's so many great things to
talk about with this episode alone so
let's only focus on what we kind of
don't give a [ __ ] about
let's see kick off with that that always
goes great anything guys okay anything
cause here's the truth i got nothing i
think it's all good oh it's all good
subversion you went in a circle to where
we least expected you i even like kenny
a lot kenny's great it's a bit of a
repeat beat of the karate kid world
i'd say i just discovered this note in
my head as i was talking
bullied kid going in i thought that's
happened with many of a cobra kai and a
piaggy doe all right
people sign up for both of these
that's the karate kid formula that's
what happened with hawk's eye
hot guy huck
his name's just hawk
that's that's what happened with hockey
right
and to see where he's at now so i'm
wondering what different path it has to
it has to carve some different path
maybe and i don't want to get too bogged
down into theories
maybe
just maybe give me like 20 minutes to
explain this theory
essentially possibly
is that
he's gonna robbie's going to see the
path that kenny goes down and kenny's
going to morph into like a little hawk
right
and he's going to be like oh [ __ ] this
is bad
this is bad
cobra kai bad look what cobra kai do to
kenny this was a kind child and now he's
a monster that's how i imagine robbie's
inner monologues
kenny wants good kenny now bad
me bad cause kenny bear
what do
what do the inner thinkings of robbie
you guys nailed it yeah man
yeah man
i love it no but i love it i root for
the kid a lot not like robbie i do he's
a good actor that guy
he's good to punch you could kick it you
know what i'm saying guys it's late at
night come on it's new year's eve and
we're shooting this i have an andrew
take it away what easter eggs did you
notice uh well there was
there was a couple uh
i always look guy that was uh we got
that one uh trying to catch the fish
reminded me of going after the fly with
the chopsticks for daniel yeah um you
mentioned bill and ted the song earlier
two heads are better than one that movie
did come out in 1981 the same year
karate kid part three which obviously is
a big heavy influence of this entire
season that is on the fly just saying
and just saying
you even mentioned too that most people
might not get this one but it's not a
reference but i just kind of thought
about this when you said he just needed
to put his home ponytail back to get his
mojo back kind of reminded me a little
bit of uh major league two came out in
1994 charlie sheen had a mental
christ-essential uh thing going on where
he couldn't figure out how to throw hard
but when he got the haircut he could
throw hard again because that's how it
takes a bit i'm a baseball instructor
that's all you need to throw a 99 mile
an hour fastball you just need to get it
here oh damn that's impressive man that
knowledge is impressive yeah i mean the
ponytail is more symbolic you know yeah
and obviously all these years he's never
put his hair in a ponytail that's what i
thought
if he had he would just snap and start
killing him
and of course we got the music too from
karate kid part three whenever he's uh
with terry silver's like theme uh so i
thought that was cool we got to harp
back on that but yeah i like how there's
such a build
like chris is so
it's like seducing him into this
the emperor he is the cobra he is the
snake
and you're watching him potentially do
this to somebody who is equally adept at
like sociopathic cobra-ing slithering
around his soul and wrapping his whole
cobra philosophy around him and ruining
his life and appealing to the to the
tender young man he once won oh we
stopped the snake references okay
and i gotta say also too and i gotta say
also too i thought it was a great idea
by the the writers and the creators of
the show not just going immediately into
terry joining up with
uh with chris i like seeing that you
know that as we mentioned earlier that
existential crisis where like you know
he he's comfortable with the life he's
uh
you know he felt he hit rock bottom
after what happened right get part three
and then obviously we got the subversion
of expectations with what happened in
episode one but i thought that was
actually a very brilliant choice by the
writers just you know giving us that
build up to you know getting his mojo
back and coming back to working with
crease and all that so i thought that
was a very smart and wise choice this
shows like the ensemble keeps getting
bigger and they keep
they still manage to keep it really
focused we balanced where is
dimitri's girlfriend
oh yasmin yeah we haven't seen her at
all yet or moo or moon right no never
said she turned true bye
yeah we're still neat we still need
those women back in here but yeah no i
mean
watching watching their relationship
unfold is a big highlight of what we've
been getting so far and terry silver is
uh
shaping up to be one hell of a great
character
party who's like don't go back and the
other part is
we're on episode four now come on man
get back
he was my favorite character in part
three i wanted to go back oh no we all
do excuse that star of part three yeah
he was great but uh also what i loved
that this episode did we got some really
good character moments uh with sam and
miguel i like how their interactions uh
especially miguel and daniel and sam and
johnny there were some really good
in-depth moments uh
for their characters giving them some
arcs too because miguel from his point
of view he's not good enough to be with
a larusso uh you know i'm not going to
go to college i don't have money so
clearly i'm not good it's like dude i
was you back in the day and then with
sam you know she feels like uh she's got
to do kind of what her parents think is
best for her and just go that path you
know daniel makes joking mentions like
oh she's going to run the dealership
she's going to go to this college one
day and she's like i kind of want to
just build my own future and then johnny
kind of just puts that back into her
head and then he gets she immediately
gets that text conveniently five to ten
minutes later saying don't do anything i
wouldn't do and then well the way that
jump was shot was really weird yeah i
literally thought we were getting our
mission impossible like five different
cuts and then i was like what the [ __ ]
is going on taking three get this weird
like pov shot like her hip down with her
like yeah to really sell it i liked some
of that but it is like
wait wait you got every shot you
i liked it though you know i like how
they are learning from each other and
then you know this tease of what might
become of the the envious side of it
because
you know one thing that the show really
does well is mix and matching like the
parallels the metaphors of the character
dynamics of how like you know in a lot
of ways
johnny was miyagi to miguel who was like
danny you guys get what i'm trying to
say right i didn't say that properly but
you guys get where i'm going at but that
and now a student being taken away and
now having to deal with the contemption
that naturally falls out of that
it's hard for a guy like johnny you know
so i i love how they are mixing and
matching um everything around here it's
like they're really having fun with like
their different puzzle pieces and where
they can throw characters into random
situations like with the cobra kai
students learning some miyagi stuff and
really learning and the miguel though in
a lot of ways is
is more like danny you know than he is
like johnny you know and i i love that
about how they've really i like when
they do focus on that i think they have
really good chemistry together um
who's the guy that plays miguel again
what's that um
zochi gomez yeah yeah
uh yeah
someone's been watching i think his name
is
isn't that his name it's a very good
shabbos yeah
yeah what do you mean someone's watching
videos on how to say that say that name
so she gomez yeah isn't it like i've
heard her glasses
i thought his name was blue beetle no no
no no
okay that's miguel how are you it's how
you say it how did you say how do you
say it mcgill
you say the gio part okay
miguel garcia play it back everyone he
goes miguel i'm overdoing it right now
to make my point miguel but you go
miguel
hey so our our biggest question in the
last episode was how does
how does a phone break when it falls on
grass and that's what we want
our biggest question now in this one how
do you put up how do you put as of this
how do you put a lot of milk into a
locker room without it leaking out
yeah they got these kids really have
time to bully don't they
yeah they have time to defy the laws of
physics in order to bully the sport damn
but they're really yeah i think they're
really good at blending and using
perspective on this show and really
showing you that even the most
villainous or most innocent seeming of
characters
has the potential with the right
motivation and the right you know uh
no yeah no no i agree with you i i
really gotta i gotta say i thought you
guys i couldn't see i thought you guys
were like talking to each other no no i
was just i was agreeing with my finger
but i was gonna say i really thought
i really thought for a moment though
when kenny was being bullied again on
the oh and you mentioned other
references to when he was being when he
kept on running off the mat just like
danny in the first uh film where he kept
running up the mat
just thought about that like in the
first film just thought about that but
you know when when he's getting bullied
by by even the cobra kai kids about hey
go home to mommy i thought we were gonna
get our water boy moment where he's like
stop making fun of me and seeing like
different people's heads like
that he was gonna see anthony or
something and philly larusso like and
then just tackle him like give him our
water boy moment well the last episode
we didn't even point out a big easter
egg was when he when kenny is
running away in costume and hopping over
the fence ah yes that's a good one yeah
but danny didn't make it over danny
didn't make it over the fence but force
correction still an easter egg and he
threw away the the shower costume just
saying he didn't keep it on
yeah
i'm curious what they're gonna do with
kenny because i feel like we have seen
with characters like hawk as you
mentioned the sort of like okay this kid
clearly has a lot of pain and anger from
the way people treat him so i can see
how he would rise to becoming a villain
but the way they have drawn kenny seems
so kind and so good-natured that it
makes me wonder how he is ultimately
going to interface with the deeper
realms of kobrakai well i'm saying the
mentorship that robbie has with kenny
that's going to affect his relationship
with the rest of cobra kya i think
absolutely
guys he's going to die and we're going
to say holy [ __ ] they killed kenny
that's what's going to happen he's going
to die for the next six episodes
each time
we're really going third with the world
of the all valley tournament here yeah
well i don't know why they really need
terry silver
well i don't know yeah i mean other than
chris wants some moral support i guess
and somebody to mastermind i don't know
maybe he needs terry to go out and
sociopath up all these kids or something
yeah
bring him to his they can bring him to
his mansion and train them there
i'm really looking forward to seeing how
they unfold that
but this is going to create odds and
dynamics with uh
johnny and
you guys know okay look we love the show
it's time to wrap this up all right we
got more to watch more to watch but this
is great this is every episode is great
i don't think i've ever seen a episode
of cobra and i know we got like [ __ ]
this yeah episode i think i've ever seen
one episode
i know we got to wrap this up but one
last thing i just want to mention we
didn't talk about i love that we were uh
we're getting some more flashbacks of
crease and
thank you for bringing that i love that
we're getting that because that was one
of my favorite dynamics in uh cobra kai
season three was their relationship uh
and then seeing them in vietnam and now
getting to see the i mean that's what we
were told obviously in karate kid part
three but actually seeing like how they
got their tattoos and starting up
kobrakai and all that i just think it's
a real uh cool layer that we have not
seen unfolded or even been really told
about but now just actually seeing it
unfold is just a really interesting
dynamic for me yeah they got matching
tats mm-hmm you got to start a dojo if
you get matching tats you can't just bow
out of that come on john i have matching
tats mm-hmm it's a photo of you andrew
yeah not bad not a bad rip cage have you
john where's yours you're my bicep yeah
nice and it's half of your face on one
half of your face on the other and then
we're starting i thought you got it in
school i thought you guys i thought you
guys would get the fact memorization
i thought you guys would get the
starship troopers tattoos but that works
too
no no i don't like that that's an
interesting tattoo okay at andrew
gordon's
dojo we would really advise against the
search jordan
dojo does not
accept a tattoo
we know what andrew gordon would really
want it's not that starship trooper [ __ ]
the tattoo is actually just several
dates and directors of obscure movies
all right guys listen i hope you're new
years shaping up strong
loving this show
he had some terry silver powder
beforehand he's trying to clear it out
of his nose
i'm still waiting for that cocaine
montage that's all the show needs
that's how it's going to end
ditches all of them on a coke bedroom
they all for johnny danny
terry
all right guys thank you thanks for
being me and
adelia chamberlain we have reached the
new year
2022 to be exact
and adelia one of the highlights for
me not john
in 2021
was meeting you at the schmodown
spectacular now granted
john was getting recognized left and
right while i sat in the corner
just being like man
but then you found me pulled me out of
the crowd
and said greg it's me and delia
i came here mainly to meet you
i couldn't give a [ __ ] about the
showdown i just wanted to say hi to you
and give you a hug
deal yet that meant the world to me that
meant the absolute world i didn't want
to be there while all these [ __ ] were
crawling all up in john's [ __ ] that
day it was too much look out look how
we've pained him to deal with that many
women crawling up his [ __ ] i think i
care about them
she he could care less about them he
cares about him you would you
you going against the earlier part of
the shadow he cares about you first and
foremost
and i care about you
i love you man
i love you so much
i i pop a fool for you
he would have seen him do it i saw some
david a movies recently
every day
and watch
street kings
fury yeah
so yeah
you're my david a your essay
you
sm chamberlain right there keeping it
real
stay real in 2022 adelia don't cap
anybody who doesn't deserve it
[Music]